immer wenn es richtung sommer geht
werden wir vermehrt auch videos auf
youtube vorgeschlagen in amerika gibt es
riesige kanäle vidal mit den ganzen tag
nur noch verlorenen gegenständen und
teuren schätzen in badeseen und flüssen
suchen und obwohl das ganze mit riesigem
aufwand verbunden ist hat mich der
gedanke nicht losgelassen das ganze mal
selber auszuprobieren und vielleicht
auch zu schauen ob es wirklich möglich
ist als laie etwas zu finden und
vielleicht sogar geld damit zu verdienen
viel spaß also mit dem ersten teil von
und mit decken und ganz kurz wir sind
natürlich weiter unser büro herum bauen
dazu kommt bald auch ein update video
wenn ihr euch in der zwischenzeit aber
schon dafür interessiert wie es hier
weitergeht was wir gerade so machen den
check in zeiten der video beschreibung
ab dort findet ihr den kanal und die
videos von tobi der ein bisschen mehr
noch begleitet hat wie es hier im büro
gerade weiter check das aus und lassen
und es gibt natürlich eine person die
mir weiterhelfen kann die mir sagen kann
was muss ich beim tauchen beachten wie
sieht es mit regelungen in deutschland
aus und potenziell auch ein bisschen was
zu erzählen hat und das ist robert
markley
was denkst du dass ich was erzählen kann
erst mal grundsätzlich macht gibt es zu
beachten kann ich überhaupt in
deutschland vernünftig tauchen gehen ich
würde lieber woanders hingehen weil sie
woanders keiner ist aber ok man kann in
deutschland schon vernünftig 1000 gehen
es gibt ja super coole seen flüsse in
not auch sender also überall kannst du
eigentlich tauchen gehen und ich glaube
die wichtigste regel die man immer
beachten muss ist auch nie allein das
ist aller aller wichtigste meine aufgabe
oder die aufgabe die ich mir selber
gestellt habe wäre aber ja verlogen
dinge zu finden im besten fall irgendwas
wertvoll ist wenn das rauchen erlaubt
ist dann kann man da schon mal gucken ob
man irgendwas findet dann ist noch die
frage was du findest wenn du befindest
grundsätzlich erst mal geil wenn du den
mitnimmst arbeite ich dabei selber nicht
in gefahr bringt und sich selber
verletzt weil es gibt ja auch
munitionsreste und ähnliches aber es
geht auch sachen die dürftest du auf gar
keinen fall auch nur annähernd anpassen
das sind archäologische fundstücke da
brauchst dann immer ein archäologe was
brauche ich alles an ausrüstungen um im
endeffekt wirklich unter wasser atmen
und mich frei bewegen zu können die
tauchflaschen ansicht die gibt es in
verschiedenen größen von kleinen bis
riesengroß von einzelnen bis doppeln
jacket also ein auftriebskörper bläst
ein bisschen luft rein steigt auf oder
lässt ein bisschen luft raus und singst
wieder ab dann brauchst du flossen in
anzügen taucher messer tauchcomputer ein
kompass nicht auch maske und wer noch
fragen hat fragt er jetzt commander
krieger der weiß ist alles auswendig ich
danke dir vielmals ich werde mich auf
machen in dem rauchstopp und mal schauen
was die mir so erzählen was ist ja wie
verkaufen der bestimmt viele sachen die
man um das lustigste ist dass du niemals
alleine darum geht es auch mal schön
sicher niemals selbst natürlich hätte
ich mir die sachen auch laien können
weil ich das dieses jahr aber ein
bisschen vermehrt machen will habe ich
mich dazu entschieden mir eigene sachen
zuzulegen deswegen bin ich zu einem der
tausch hier in köln gefahren lass mich
jetzt beraten und kaufe alles was ich
brauche
entschieden habe ich mich dazu einen
eigenen atemregler zu kaufen so eine
eigene abc ausrüstung also flossen und
maske und dazu ein tauchcomputer der im
prinzip aus der birne deutlich zu große
ruhe mit deutlichen mehrheit funktionen
die uns anzeigen kann wie tief wir sind
wahr wenn es wasser gegangen sind und so
weiter jacket und neoprenanzug habe ich
nicht gekauft weil ich da ein bisschen
rumprobieren wollte um das richtige für
mich zu finden und was soll ich sagen
ich habe knapp 1000 euro für meine
tauchausrüstungen ausgegeben und
vielleicht kennt ihr das selber ihr seid
umgezogen oder hat daneben eine teure
anschaffung zu machen und dadurch jetzt
einem verbraucherkredit gefahren aber
kein problem denn die firmen unterstützt
nicht nur mich bei meinem video sondern
auch euch bei eurem raten oder
kreditprobleme das gesamtangebot von
annie film richtet sich nur an leute die
bereits in einem kredit drin hängen und
dadurch also schon bereits verschuldet
sind ihr ladet euch die app rund um in
dieser die letzte rate abrechnungen oder
kreditkartenabrechnung hochzuladen
entfielen frühstücken ratenkäufe auf
bedingungen und schaut ob es eine
möglichkeit gibt den kredit günstiger zu
machen wenn das der fall ist und auch
wirklich nur wenn es der fall ist
bekommt ihr ein angebot und könnt euch
dann entscheiden ob dies annehmen wollte
oder nicht das ganze ist komplett
kostenlos und unverbindlich und falls
ihr euch fragt wie zur hölle das
funktionieren soll habe ich jetzt die
antwort für euch entfernen sorgt dafür
dass der kredit auf einmal abbezahlt
wird und durch ihr euch in vielen fällen
ein angebot mit weniger zinsen machen
können gleichzeitig wird es dadurch
deutlich flexibler ihr könnt selber
einstellen in welchem tempo er die raten
zurückzahlen wollte und bis zu zwei
raten 1000 jahren liegt im web gibt es
auch noch ein super kundenservice falls
noch irgendwelche fragen dann klickt
also auf den ersten blick ein video
beschreibung benutzt day für 20 euro
rabatt und fangt an eure kredite mit
andy hin zu optimieren ich bedanke mich
für weit dass die mich an dieses gesamte
projekt unterstützen und jetzt viel spaß
weiter mit dem und so schnell kann es
gehen gestern die erste ausrüstung
gekauft heute direkt am fühlinger see
der see um in köln tauchen zu gehen und
dann gehen wir heute direkt ins wasser
und schauen mal ob wir irgendwas hin
können was leute hier im letzten sommer
beim baden oder so verloren ich bin
unheimlich gespannt dass einer der
bestbesuchten sehen in köln also die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass wir etwas finden
ist tatsächlich gar nicht so gering
jetzt sehen wir uns um und dann geht's
ins wasser ich habe völlig vergessen
euch zu erzählen dass ich natürlich sind
auch schön habt den habe ich 2018 auf
thailand gemacht gesamt habe ich 50
tauchgänge auf dem buckel und ein etwas
entscheiden was bedeutet dass sich mit
einem buggy auf bis zu 30 meter
runtergehen darf natürlich ist das
tauchen in dem deutschen sie überhaupt
nicht mit dem tauchen in thailand zu
vergleichen weswegen ich erst mal ein
bisschen rein fliegen und keine ahnung
wie kalt es wird wir werden jetzt sehen
aber das wetter ist wunderbar noch nicht
gut genug dafür die ganzen badegäste da
sind aber das ist natürlich optimal für
uns sind 14 grad ja vom rein gehen ganz
wichtig der bodycheck natürlich gehen
wir nicht alleine erstens ist verboten
und zweitens mega dumm aber wir sind für
unsere buddy natürlich nicht nur unter
wasser in notsituationen füreinander da
sondern auch schon vorher um zu
kontrollieren dass wir möglichst nicht
in notsituationen kommen weswegen man
immer vom tauchen ein bodycheck macht
derweil die kontrolliert alles an meiner
tauchausrüstung und natürlich mache ich
das auch gegenseitig beim 1 die
anspannung ist immer weiter gestiegen
weil man irgendwie so das innere gefühl
hatte jetzt gleich irgendwas wertvolles
irgendwas verrücktes zu finden gerade
weil robert mack lehmann im vorgespräch
ein bisschen erzählt hat was er so
gefunden hat das älteste mädchen skelett
auf dem amerikanischen kontinent da
waren wir in dieser höhle mit tauchen
wir haben in mammut skelett gefunden
schädel von krokodilen habe ich schon in
höhlen gefunden einen zahn von einem
mammut gibt es auch im kinofilm
tatsächlich darüber und ich habe sogar
schon mal eine waffe aus dem ersten
weltkrieg gefunden das bei mir zu hause
ich komme eigentlich bei einem tauchgang
raus und habt nichts dabei
und dann hieß es das erste mal abtauchen
und nach verlorenen dick
[Musik]
erst mal was völlig ungewohnt ich muss
mich erstmal wieder ins tauchen gewinnen
irgendwann konnte man sich dann ein
bisschen besser darauf fokussieren nach
dingen zu suchen wirklich ausschau zu
halten auf seine umgebung zu achten und
einfach zu schauen ob man irgendetwas
finden kann was an der oberfläche liegt
und noch nicht unter den mengen
amüsanten zu graben wurde tatsächlich
hat der erste punkt auch gar nicht so
lange auf sich warten lassen wir haben
eine tüte gefunden die unter wasser so
für mich außer als werden nochmal etwas
verpackt in der tüte gewesen also
potenziell irgendwas was wir nicht
hätten finden soll
wir haben eine tüte mit einem stein aber
naja der erste fund ich war happy und
will kommt ein bisschen will aus dem see
mitnehmen erst mal weiter tauchen und
nach weiteren dingen
[Musik]
wir haben direkt gemerkt dass es gar
nicht so einfach ist dinge aufsicht zu
finden wie wir gedacht hat gehen wir mal
davon aus jemanden verliert beim baden
sein iphone oder seine go.de sinkt es
auf den boden und viele andere leute
laufen rum und wirbeln wieder am boden
irgendwas auf das bedeutet die sachen
sinken potenziell direkt ein bisschen
absicht irgendwann ist quasi unendlich
metalldetektor bild dapd
nichtsdestotrotz konnten wir weitere
sachen
damit hat unser tauchgang lange endet es
ist tatsächlich unendlich kalt geworden
auf zeit wir kommen was finden haben
aber auch gleichzeitig gemerkt wohnen so
schwach schnell ist auf sicht ist es
einfach super schwer was zu finden wir
wussten also dass wir schwere geschütze
auf also habe ich mir so ziemlich den
besten metalldetektor gekauft den für
unterwasser suche gibt
[Musik]
wir sind wieder da zweiter versuch also
wieder anziehen und den größten
anfängerfehler machen den mama
[Musik]
ja und natürlich war alles kaputt ich
musste mir sachen leyen aber aus fehlern
lernt man und es wird mir nicht noch ein
weiteres mal passieren da steht ein
metalldetektor guy im wasser das ist das
zeichen dafür dass ist was zu holen also
auch zu tauchgang zwei wir hatten
richtig viel glück und dabei einen
großen metalldetektor den wir natürlich
unter wasser so nicht hören können
weswegen ich noch mal unter wasser
kopfhörer an dem metalldetektor
angeschlossen habe die ich dann über
meine maske und über meine taucher
darüber hatte der jäger nachdem ich im
boden ab gleich gemacht habe und dem
metalldetektor eingestellt habe was
super wichtig ist damit eher einfach
flüssig und rund läuft
habe ich direkt gemerkt alter gelegt
mega viel im boden rum so einfach war es
dann aber doch nicht
sobald wir den ausgleich hatten haben
wir uns gemeinsam daran gemacht den
boden abzusuchen wir konnten mit dem
winter ziemlich genau die position des
metallischen gegenstand ausmachen wir
haben es aber einfach nicht aus dem
boden raus bekommen werden dicke
handschuhe an der boden ist super feind
man wird unheimlich viel auf sieht
dadurch weniger entweder werden sand in
der hand und das hauptgebiet oder ist es
runter gefallen und werden kein signal
mehr also es war unheimlich schwierig
die sachen wirklich raus zu bekommen
weswegen sich dann dazu entschieden hat
die handschuhe auszuziehen um einfach
ein bisschen besseres gefühl zu haben
auch das hat aber langfristig nicht dazu
geführt dass wir es hinbekommen haben
sachen wirklich aus dem boden raus zu
bekommen was super ärgernis war auf der
anderen seite könnten wir natürlich
deutlich schneller ab wenn man ohne
handschuhe taucht das bedeutet obwohl
ich jetzt knapp 2000 euro für die
komplette ausrüstung inklusive
metalldetektor ausgegeben haben konnten
wir nicht auf anhieb etwas finden das
war deutlich schwieriger als gedacht
eine geburt
einfach wie gedacht
startete bekommen
wo lag wirklich
unendlich gebrochen mussten wir uns
geschlagen geben und haben das wasser
auch nach dem zweiten tauchgang ohne
wertvollen gegenstand verlassen ein
gebrochener mann ich habe 2000 euro
ausgegeben wir haben nichts rausgeholt
außer eine geschlossene capri sonne und
das war nicht mal ein plastik strohhalm
dran also keine besonders großen runde
ich bin aber angefixt ich will es
weitermachen und wenn ihr lust habt ihr
weiter diese videos zur verfolgung an
der lust habt auf weitere folgen von
diesem format dann lassen wir ihr
vergesst nicht den kanal zu abonnieren
dann sehen wir uns hoffentlich in den
nächsten wochen wieder wenn ich eine
rolex oder fette goldbarren aus dem
fühlinger see
die monarchie finden